greetings fellow friends and subscribers
as you may know while on vacation I was
logged on YouTube on public computer
forgot to log off and someone got on and
deleted all my friends and on the videos
so I had to go back and manually send
276 friend invites as well as messages
explained the situation found out that
most of the messages didn't get through
and it took me about two 1/2 hours later
found out probably I could do it in
around ten most of the videos was not
backed up due to the C Drive crash about
a year ago so all the videos before this
video I'll only videos I could find but
there's good news coming up with the new
effects reel with all new footage that
you guys never seen before coming out
with a photography trail of all my
pictures and I'm also coming out with
like some time-lapse cloud thing and I
also got business cards I do need your
help though to get back up to our months
was I need you guys to do a couple of
things for me when the new videos come
out I need you to first comment rate
subscribe if you haven't subscribed
already but before you do that you have
to watch me at first yeah
that'll help me out well so I want to
thank my friends my subscribers and
everyone that washington videos thank
you very much